[Music]
thank you
I'm so excited I'm with the Ariana
Dubose today at this awesome Premiere
Ariana you are killing it with hosting
from the fastest to the Tonys last night
unbelievable what is your secret and
would you do the Oscars oh my gosh I
don't have a secret but I will tell you
I did not host the Baptist I did perform
on them I don't take credit that I'm not
owed I promise you stole the show thank
you that sweet
um I don't know what my secret is I
think when you host you gotta like
people and and yeah I think you have to
like the community you're asked to show
up for
um and I I love the theater Community I
love Broadway it's where I started
um would I ever host the Oscars in the
right circumstances maybe but I think
we're a long way away from that so now
as people can see speaking of oscars you
won an Oscar you're still so humble and
kind in interviews is it tempting to
change when you win an Oscar like does
that kind of go in your head no not at
all I I hope I never lose who I was I
feel very much the same person I maybe
have better clothes and more
opportunities which I'm very grateful
for but
I think when you lose your your Humanity
that's the beginning of your Artistry
falling apart as well and I really hope
that never happens to me no and it's
clearly not and with ISS premiering
tonight for this kind of space roll do
you sit down lay out the space DVDs like
2001 gravity and for prep are you still
watching DVDs I mean no I'm not I have
to say no I do have an extensive DVD
collection though I'm very proud of it
um
I didn't actually watch a ton of space
film for it I I wanted to go into the
experience of working with Gabriella and
everyone and just sort of
dive into her process
um so I just tried to use my my own
access to my body to sort of you know be
a good actor make it work I mean we'll
find out won't we but I just had a good
time now mind you I love gravity Sandra
Bullock's my queen and I also love
Apollo 13 like there's nothing better
like I don't know
yeah yeah well this is going to go in
that group I'm excited for people to see
it the last question before they go are
you excited for the Ariana Dubose action
figures at our coma Crave in the Hunter
um
potentially yeah I think it's cool
anytime there's
something like that that happens you
know I mean there are Asha dolls for
wish I can't believe they're using my
voice for that I'm I'm just kind of
tickled pink that these sort of things
are happening I never thought that would
be me my I thought it was going to be
Madonna's backup dancer you know so to
have opportunities like this is really
cool well thank you for talking to me
and being inspiration to so many I
appreciate it here